was a child abuse gang at large in the
city of hull a two-year police operation
called marksman examined this question
but was wound down by homicide police in
the spring of 2021 without any men being
charged a few months later sky news
spoke to some of the alleged victims and
produced a series of reports revealing
evidence of organized abuse in the city
as well as a new alleged victim in the
case
back then the police said they had done
everything they could but now the women
at the center of this have been told
that the case is being reopened and it
is testament to their courage and
persistence that a new investigative
team will look into it
humberside police asked an external
sexual abuse review body called
operation hydrant to look at the
evidence in this case and now assistant
chief constable david marshall said
based on hydrant's evidential review of
op marksmen humberside police have taken
the decision to establish a new
investigative team and re-commence the
investigation
the investigation team will focus on a
number of lines of inquiry with the
victims being updated and receiving our
full support
we've decided not to re-interview the
victims in this case but spoke to a
victim's friend who is part of a support
network for abuse survivors
they're feeling happy that it's reopened
but the turmoil they've had to go
through to get it reopened is
traumatized in itself
when the police don't believe you
and social services don't believe you
you internalize that
the strength that they've shown is
phenomenal these women have paved the
way for other women to come forward
because most people would think police
investigations closed that's it your
chance is over yeah they didn't give up
they didn't give up for themselves and
for the other survivors coming forward
sky news assessed the case last autumn
with the help of a leading child abuse
expert after examining diaries texts
school reports photos of injuries and
testimonies of the women jim gamble said
this i'd be surprised if they're not
able to pass the evidential threshold
because what you do have is you have
significant levels of corroboration is
your gut feeling that this this case
should be tested in court
oh absolutely
i mean
if they need additional evidence
then go out and get it
in the initial investigation 34 people
were arrested and 200 digital devices
seized this new probe will be just as
complex and with the passing of time
possibly an even more difficult task
jason farrell sky news